Chris Ruffo tirelessly is honestly broke
this story he's a felt that man had an
Institute he joins us tonight Chris
thanks so much for coming on
um so I just have to ask you once again
how is this which is so obviously
illegal under federal and state laws all
50 states how is this allowed
uh well it shouldn't be but it's allowed
because these are people who have power
they've expanded in the universities
with these so-called diversity equity
and inclusion programs and no one is
challenging them from within the
institution and so that's why I'm doing
this investigative series I'm exposing
it we're going to put pressure on these
folks because what they're doing is
quite simple they're dividing Americans
or in this case students at Florida
State along what they call a matrix of
Oppression they're designating some
group suppressors other groups oppressed
and they're creating special benefits
and special punishments uh based on your
identity it's wrong we have them
scrambling and the more we expose it the
more we put pressure on them the more
that we could stamp out this racialist
ideology that is capturing all of our
institutions
well and it's just it's directly opposed
to the America that normal people want
to live in of all colors by the way
um you're not prepared for this I'm just
throwing this at you I just read today
that you've been appointed to the board
of a college by Governor DeSantis in
Florida and in a minute 30 can you sum
up what it said very interesting story
can you sum up what you're doing and
what that is
yeah I was appointed along with six
other trustees to take over the new
College of Florida it's the smallest
Public University in the system on our
first board meeting we fired the
president we let go of the general
counsel we switched the board chair and
we're going to implement top to bottom
reforms at this University uh we're
going to bring be bringing a classical
liberal arts education and demonstrating
it's time for conservatives to get tough
It's time for when when we win elections
to actually start changing institutions
uh and and we're not just simply going
to be the caretakers of left-wing
ideology we're taking action Governor
Ron DeSantis is leading the way and I'm
proud to be part of this movement
so you're not waiting around for a
report from the current administration
at this college
we're acting very quickly and I think
you're going to see dramatic changes
right from the outset and look we're
following the governor's lead this is a
guy who has a bold Vision takes
courageous action and and really the
thing that I hope to demonstrate in this
experiment taking over this college is
political courage because that's what we
need as conservatives it stopped it's
time to stop just doing white papers
talking to each other it's time to take
action
you know John Durham is going to do a
report uh in the next 10 years so just
just hold tight Chris Ruffo
congratulations great to see you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight